Suma las dos expresiones y combina
términos semejantes.
Y bueno, tengo estas dos expresiones de aquí
y para eso déjame sacar mi libreta de notas.
Suma las dos expresiones y
combina términos semejantes
y tengo, "6y" más 2 menos 2/3 menos "y".
Y bueno, como quiero combinar términos semejantes,
entonces déjame apuntarlos justo aquí.
Me va a quedar...
déjame agarrar este color, el color azul...
y me va a quedar "6y"...
"6y" más 2, ok, a esto le voy a
sumar -2/3 menos "y",
a esto le voy a sumar -2/3 menos "y", de lujo.
Y bueno, en primero lugar tengo "6y"  y a esto le voy a quitar "1y",  si tengo 6 de algo y le quito una vez ese algo,
me queda con 5 veces ese algo, "6y" menos "y" es lo mismo que 5 veces "y".
Ok, esto está de lujo y después tengo esta
parte de aquí, más 2 menos 2/3 y bueno,
eso lo podemos resolver de este lado.
Tengo 2 menos 2/3 y es que 2 lo podemos escribir
en tercios de la siguiente manera, como 6/3,
6 entre 3 es lo mismo que 2, ok, menos 2/3.
Y bueno 6/3 menos 2/3 es lo mismo que 4/3...
que 4/3 y por lo tanto me va a quedar "5y" más 4/3.
Si simplifico estas expresiones que tengo aquí, después de sumarlas, llego al resultado de "5y" más 4/3.
Ahora, es justo el momento de sacar aquí
mi navegador...
lo tengo justo por aquí...
y escribir nuestra respuesta correcta.
Aquí voy a escribir 5 veces "y"...
5 veces "y" y a esto le voy a sumar...
le voy a sumar 4/3...
4/3...
y bueno, puedes verificar que si lo interpretó
de una manera correcta
y es hora de comprobar la respuesta...
De lujo. Estamos bien.